ah oui David Assouline vous avez
interrogé le gouvernement sur le
mouvement actuel de grève des
journalistes du Journal de dimanche du
dimanche pour protester contre la
nomination de Geoffroy Lejeune à la tête
de la rédaction Geoffre le jeune qui est
un ancien du journal Valeurs Actuelles
vous avez interrogé le gouvernement mais
finalement qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire
c'est une entreprise privée il n'a pas
trop son mot à dire la question que j'ai
posée était précise c'est qu'on peut
légiférer ça on peut légiférer bien
entendu c'est pas le gouvernement qui
nomme les patrons de presse et encore
mais justement c'est pas la question que
j'ai posée donc j'ai posé une question
qui était déjà posée à travers la
commission d'enquête sur la
concentration des médias que nous avons
produit au Sedat et ce thème revenait à
tous les niveaux parce qu'il y a pas que
le cas des entreprises de Bolloré mais
là il y a urgence c'est que de à partir
du moment où des actionnaires qui sont
dans des grands groupes industriels qui
ont volonté en France très français de
s'emparer de groupes d'informations de
médias ou de presse alors que leurs
activités n'ont rien à voir vous
regardez Bouygues soit d'activités c'est
le BTP vous regardez
Altice c'est les fournisseurs d'accès et
la téléphonie vous regardez les choses
on informe que on parle bien de Vincent
Bolloré qui est l'actionnaire maintenant
du couple Lagardère qui détient le JDD
vous avez des grands groupes et
à chaque fois les rédactions
subissent des interférences des
actionnaires elles sont attachées à leur
indépendance à leur liberté alors il y a
un moyen de faire parce qu'on peut
comprendre qu'un actionnaire qui achète
un journal et bien il a envie de nommer
directeur ça ça a tout va bien encore
mais bien entendu c'est l'interface avec
la rédaction et c'est l'interface pour
l'actionnaire probablement mais ça doit
être interface de l'autre côté et si il
est rejeté comme aujourd'hui au par 98%
de la rédaction c'est pas rien il doit y
avoir une solution et donc des
rédactions des journaux ont décidé de
mettre des seuils de véto possible par
les rédactions il y a les échos il y a
aussi le monde et moi je pense que 60%
c'est pas mal
et donc on peut très bien imaginer un
dispositif qui fasse que à chaque fois
qu'un directeur d'une rédaction est
nommée parce que ce n'est pas une
entreprise comme les autres parce que ce
n'est pas une marchandise comme les
autres la formation pour protéger la
liberté de la presse il y ait cette
acceptation soumise au suffrage des
rédactions voilà c'est c'est simple ce
que je propose merci beaucoup à David
assoline pour votre réaction et bonne
continuation merci je le rappelle vous
quittez le Sénat après 19 ans de mandats
à la hautation blé merci beaucoup
[Musique]